vous n'auriez pas vu les billets non non
non pas des m'as été l'un des premiers
clown à la télévision parfois accompagné
de son ami ssol habsheim
mais ça c'est vous oui oui oui dans les
têtes toulousaines n'ont alors pas et
moi les pompiers s'il vous plaît c'était
le bhoutan parce qu'elles ont créé
beaucoup
il y avait beaucoup d'improvisation à 91
ans louis de santis garde de très bons
souvenirs de ses débuts dans l'émission
pour enfants la boîte à surprises
diffusée à radio canada à la fin des
années 50 dans tout le canada qui a
devrait pas beaucoup
il y avait des files et c'est parce que
pas dans le fond on était c'était
nouveau
si on arrive sur le costume du cloud bi
pour la toute première fois de
l'histoire c'est en couleurs que l'on
peut voir son costume dans une
exposition consacrée aux racines du
cirque présenté à latouille à chaque
fois qu'il était qu'il était vu par le
spectateur se teint noir et blanc il y
avait tout un imaginaire du clown qui a
été vraiment très fort
l'art du cirque a vu le jour en 1796 au
québec c'était principalement de
l'animation de rue puis avec le temps
des compagnies de cirque ont émergé une
quarantaine d'entre elles ont fourni de
leurs archives pour l'exposition tout un
cirque
la grande aventure du cirque québécois
si au québec une terre fertile pour la
création de besoins essentiels d'exister
de continuer de 2 qu'il voit qui on est
et s'est retrouvé dans le cirque
après ces soleils qui a fait que on est
passé un drop vitesse dans cette
collection on retrouve entre autres la
toute première affiche du spectacle des
échassiers qui allait devenir quatre ans
plus tard le cirque du soleil
elle est inédite personne n'a jamais
exposé il reste trois exemplaires sur
terre premier dictionnaire universel des
clones lorsque nous l'avons rencontré
louis de santis ne savait pas que son
costume de bim allait faire partie de
l'exposition à la tohu
sa famille lui préparait une surprise
pour le vernissage lui toujours aimé
faire le rigolo
faut pas prendre la vie trop pour cerner
qu'apparaissait d'être sérieux et c'est
peut-être mort dans deux minutes ici
julie jocelyne boudreault radio canada
montréal